What's the best way to treat nausea caused by cancer?
so
nausea
with cancer patients can be common and
Can be difficult because it could decrease the person's appetite
They don't want to eat and then if you don't eat and you've lost too much weight
You could go into a state of the kexia and that can be
The most dangerous thing for a cancer patient
so
Teaping one's weight up is super important for cancer
For multiple reasons if you lose too much weight your increased risk of becoming anemic
Which brings on other
Comorbidities if you lose too much weight you're not getting enough protein consumption to make
Natural killer cells and T cells which are the lymphocytes sometimes that are needed to kill cancer
There's just a lot of
Negatives to weight loss and it could always start with nausea in our store
We have some homeopathic spray. That's called not down nausea. That's helped people and we have some nausea drops
Anti nausea drops. That's helped people
Both are homeopaths, so that's something to look at
I have a blog post on nausea as well. So I look at the blog post that goes into more detail in other
Hints that you could do
To see if
If that you know that your other hints with as far as diet and food and such that you could do to help with nausea